today on the matt walsh show an
asthmatic two-year-old is kicked off a
plane for not complying with masking
regulations while video shows yet
another woman getting followed around
the grocery store and harassed by a male
member of the masking cult there's
something deeply sick in the soul of
america we'll talk about that today also
a mayor in ohio threatens to arrest the
entire school board because of
pornographic material distributed to
students and meghan markle and harry are
named one of the most influential people
in the world but they still just want
privacy most of all plus our daily
cancellation and much more today on the
matt wall show
[Music]
we've talked a lot about the texas law
banning abortion and that law has
abortion proponents going insane and
it's all great news it's great news
because it protects babies also great
news to say to see these people going
insane i think but you need to be as
prepared uh as ever
to talk about this issue when it comes
up in conversation as as it has so many
times i'm sure for you over the last
couple of weeks it's one of the reasons
that i wrote the forward to the new book
what to say when the complete new guide
to discussing abortion which became an
amazon bestseller and number one in its
category opponent's release two weeks
ago it's an easy book to use it tells
you what to say and what not to say
when the discussion um about abortion
comes up it has proven arguments that
have worked with everybody people on the
fence abortion supporters even planned
parenthood workers have found these
arguments compelling the book was
produced by 40 days for life which is
the largest grassroots pro-life
organization in the world they hold
peaceful vigils outside abortion
facilities in 1 000 cities in 64
countries and it helped convert the
hearts of 221 abortion clinic workers so
you know that they know what they're
talking about which is why you got to
get this new book what to say when the
complete new guide to discussing
abortion go to amazon or get it directly
from 40 days for life at
40daysforlife.com
we're going to begin today with a couple
of incidents that will seem familiar far
too familiar
and their familiarity is precisely the
problem first we have a young mother
named amanda pendarvis who has just
boarded an american airlines flight in
dallas pendarvis had her two-year-old
asthmatic son with her now because the
very young child is a very young child
and because he already has trouble
breathing he was resistant to wearing a
face mask the mother tried to put the
mask on him she also she says brought
paperwork proving that her son had just
received a negative covet test
but her earnest attempts to comply the
negative covet test the simple fact that
the child is only two years old and
clearly terrified and confused none of
that matters to american airlines the
flight attendant took to the intercom to
accuse the boy of being a non-compliant
traveler
and he then had the mother and the son
escorted off the plane by security
shortly before being kicked out another
passenger took a video of pendarvis and
her son showing just how
the young boy was reacting to the mask
let's just watch that for a second
[Music]
[Music]
i mean it's it's
barbaric you can hear him gasping for
breath
if that clip doesn't
fill you with ungodly fury then you have
no soul
here's how bad this is
even if the child posed a measurable
risk to the other passengers
this treatment still could not be
justified i'm no hero myself but i would
certainly rather risk getting kovid
than force a baby to wear a muzzle while
he screams and gasps for breath
if that's what it takes to avoid kovid
then it's not worth avoiding
if that's what it takes for you to not
get coveted
then i'd rather you just get coveted
whoever you are
so when an adult says well yeah but this
is in order to keep me healthy well i'd
rather you just not be healthy then i'd
rather you get sick i would rather you
get sick than see that
but the fact is that the child does not
pose a measurable risk to anyone
he has a negative covet test even if he
was even if he was positive for coming
the mother could walk on the plane with
a positive coveted test
and his chances of spreading the disease
are still very very low
meanwhile everybody on the plane all the
adults who want to be vaccinated are
vaccinated
and they're all wearing masks i ask you
what is the chance that a covid negative
two-year-old could spread covid to a
mask-wearing vaccinated adult
it's not a one percent chance
it's not a point one percent chance is
it a point zero zero one maybe a point
zero zero zero zero zero one
whatever the minuscule infinitesimal not
even mathematically quantifiable risk it
is not worth doing this to a child to
avoid it
in fact if you think it's worth doing
this to a child to avoid it then you are
scum you're a bad person i have no
respect for you as a human being and
that's the nicest thing i can say i'd be
fired if i told you what i really think
now we should note that american
airlines has mostly confirmed the
account given by the mother uh they said
in a statement on september 13th
american airlines flight 1284 returned
to the gate prior to departure from
dallas fort worth to deplane a party on
board initial reports indicate the party
refused to comply with crew member
instructions to remain seated and wear a
face mask securely over their nose and
mouth after agreeing to adhere to
federal face covering requirements all
individuals were rebooked rebooked for
travel on the next flight to colorado
can you imagine that the asthmatic
two-year-old refused to follow federal
face covering requirements
forget getting kicked off the plane
should be arrested
now i say that sarcastically but the
troubling fact is that millions of
americans at this point might actually
wish to take it that far
here's one american for example who
might uh we can only imagine how he
feels about about little babies who
don't wear masks and we still don't know
much of of the the background of this
video about to play but but the video
itself tells us everything that we need
to know this is a man
with what appears to be a severe
testosterone deficiency and i'm very
worried about him just from a medical
standpoint but he's at target um as so
many men at target tend to have that
problem
harassing a female shopper who is not
wearing a mask
you'll note that the man has a mask
also a sticker bragging about his
vaccinated status
so he's fully protected and yet
terrified of the woman who if not for
him
choosing to stalk and harass her
wouldn't have come anywhere near him
he's so afraid of her so concerned that
she could be a danger to his health that
he's following her around the store
yelling at her
watch this
really you're vaccinated yes i am oh you
are because i already have natural
immunity yeah you're not going to follow
me around in the store and point at me
to people so i will video you so we have
a state regulation
and it's not law you're an idiot yeah oh
oh so you're going to insult me now so
my wife is like
oh my god
oh is she what are you doing i'm kidding
this is between this is just me
so what leave her alone you got your
mask on your face i'm sure you're
vaccinated too he is he has a badge that
says it i do so my wife is a doctor who
specializes in infectious disease
so you know do you think that she just
doesn't know what she's talking about
it's her choice it's her choice
harass people and make sure that people
are ashamed
yeah you're making a bad decision
you're a bad american i am i totally am
and i voted for trump yeah you're a bad
person
[Music]
now i know what you're thinking
there's no way
this pot-bellied dork has a wife
yeah i find that claim suspicious as
well i also find it suspicious that it's
almost always women getting harassed in
these kinds of videos
i'm not one to pull the sexism card i
don't pull it lightly but it cannot be a
coincidence that the effeminate bumpkins
in in the mask cult always choose to
take their helpless nerd rage out on
women
i walk around maskless everywhere
and have very rarely been confronted and
never in this way
i've been waiting for that i've got to
be honest with you
i've been waiting for it i wish a guy
like this would come up to me
i'm hoping
like bring it on
on the two or three occasions when
anyone has chosen to make an issue out
of the fact that i'm not wearing a mask
they always back down and slink away
like the gutless worms they are as soon
as i tell them to piss off and leave me
alone
you know one wonders whether the men of
the mask cult have a certain amount of
sexual rage and jealousy and perhaps
they're using this issue as an excuse to
vent it
but i'll leave the psychoanalysis to
their therapists and i'm sure they all
have therapists
the greater problem perhaps
speaking of men
is that we never see any men among the
bystanders
bystanders step in
just once i wish one of these videos
would end with a real man entering the
frame to give the harasser two choices
shut your mouth and leave
or have your mask forcibly removed from
your face and shoved up where the sun
don't shine
metaphorically i mean
i would never advocate violence
publicly
as i said at the beginning
neither of these incidents are shocking
or unique we've seen this time and time
again all throughout the last year and a
half
and it's why i wish we would all spend
and i'm guilty of this too definitely
but i wish we'd all spend less time
complaining about the faucis and the
bidens
and more time talking about the average
americans who have revealed themselves
to be paranoid freaks and cowards and
power-hungry narcissists and pathetic
trembling little snitches
biden has no power on his own
no power on his own
he needs the flight attendant on that
american airlines flight
he needs that curly-haired weirdo at
target
he needs the snitches and the cowards to
do their part
what if every flight attendant in the
country said
no we are not going to force
two-year-olds to wear masks we're not
going to kick toddlers off of our planes
it's not going to happen none of us are
going to do it
what if every business owner said no
we're not going to force vaccines on our
employees we're not going to force them
to inject any substance into their
bodies
no matter how we personally feel
about whether they should or not
what if every man in the country said no
we are not going to follow women around
the grocery store and shout at them for
not wearing masks
and in fact we'll step in and defend any
woman who is treated that way
well then i'll tell you what happens the
whole edifice falls apart
because all of these policies and
regulations
they're all built on a house of cards
and the house of cards is called
compliance
they are all built on the assumption
that we will all comply or at least a
majority of us
compliance goes away and none of it
works
every flight attendant says that what
are they going to do shut down the
entire airline industry ground every
plane permanently they're not going to
do that
they're not going to do it
compliance goes away and none of it
works
the good news is that the united states
was founded on non-compliance
with tyranny
it was founded by men who said we're not
going to go along with this
with tyranny oppression we would rather
die than that
we'll put everything on the line
that's the good news
i mean that's our
heritage
nationally
the bad news is that
the united states as it was founded
is gone
and in its place is this old husk
populated by fat guys at target
screaming at women for not wearing masks
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
you know researchers have determined
that email phishing attacks and brute
force attacks are the two most popular
and successful methods cyber criminals
use on corporate networks these attacks
are simple to attempt difficult to
detect and they can come with big
rewards for cyber criminals it's
important for that reason to understand
how cyber crime and identity theft are
affecting our lives every day we put our
information at risk on the internet in
an instant a cyber criminal could harm
what's yours that's your finances your
credit um and that's why it's a good
thing that there is life luck lifelock
helps detect a wide range of identity
threats
that you might find on the internet for
example your social security number
could be for sale on the dark web many
things that
on your own you would never know were
happening
until it's too late and if they detect
the information has potentially been
compromised they will send you an alert
uh to let you know about it and if
anything does happen they also have
identity restoration specialists that
will help you take care of it as well
this is why if you don't have lifelock
you need to get it no one can prevent
all identity theft or monitor all
transactions at all businesses but you
can keep what's yours yours with
lifelock by norton join now and save up
25 off your first year by going to
lifelock.com welsh that's lifelock.com
walsh for 25 off
all right so we'll start with this uh
you know that was this
we go from it was a little depressing so
let's uh let's brighten the mood a
little bit
and
go to something that
that's encouraging and maybe can give us
a little bit of hope
so reading from the daily mail now it
says
a a mayor in ohio
has threatened the city's entire school
board with criminal charges unless they
resign over a highly sexual writing
writing prompts that teachers gave to
underage students
hudson mayor craig schubert
delivered the harsh
ultimatum during a school board meeting
on monday garnering loud applause from
outraged parents who also spoke out on
the issue
i'll tell you a little bit about these
about this writing assignment that has
been called pornographic and it is
but first let's just let's hear from
this again is uh hudson mayor craig
shubert
and let's hear him talking to the school
board listen
members of the board my name is craig
shubert i'm the mayor of this city
it has come to my attention
that your educators
are distributing essentially what is
child pornography
in the classroom
i've spoken to a judge this evening
she's already confirmed that
so i'm going to give you a simple choice
you either choose to resign from this
board of education
or you will be charged
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
that is
that almost brings a tear
to my eye
you know i think i think we've we've
added to the list of acceptable reasons
for for men to cry tears of joy
in response to that
i'd say
mayor craig shubert i don't know
anything else about him
i don't know where he stands on any
other issue but i would vote for him for
president tomorrow if it were up to me
i'd i didn't make him president of the
united states tomorrow if i could
without knowing anything else about him
because just that alone tells me that he
that puts him
uh above
almost every other republican
at every level of government everywhere
in the country
that he is willing to do that
but he's taking this issue that
seriously
and is going to use all of the power at
his disposal
to protect kids and to put an end to
this degeneracy and filth in the school
system
let's go back to the daily mail to see
what assignment he's talking about
it says at issue are the highly
inappropriate writing prompts
distributed to students in the liberal
arts writing class at hudson high school
here are the writing prompts
given to kids by adults
write a sex scene you wouldn't show your
mom
describe your favorite part of a man's
body using only verbs
and write an x-rated disney scenario
uh that those were some of the writing
problems
uh it was
continuing the article says it was
unclear whether the inappropriate
written material given to school
children truly violates child
pornography laws as the mayor claimed
but nevertheless parents in the district
were outraged i think it certainly does
um
ohio law does prohibit sending harmful
or obscene material to or sharing it
with a minor
though this statute usually refers to
sexting or sending obscene images
the relevant statute exempts obscene
material that is presented for bona fide
educational purposes leaving the legal
questions around the controversy murky
uh
yeah well they they can sort that out
but he talked to a judge
and this is the right way to handle it
this is exactly how we have to handle we
have to start talking about it
in this way
you know for me it's very simple because
we've
we've kind of we've granted this
exemption
to teachers and people in the in the
public school system
for no good reason
you know we've kind of waved the wand
and say and we've said well they're
exempt
from all of the normal rules of decency
that we apply to everybody else
so if um
if there was a grown adult
who you know your
14 year old daughter
met online
and you got to look at the the messages
going back and forth between this grown
adult and the 14 year old daughter
and uh the adult said to your daughter
uh you know was was trying to prompt
your daughter
to write x-rated things
what if he had said uh describe your
favorite your favorite part of a man's
body using only verbs
i mean what if this was some some creepy
pervert online an adult talking to your
14 year old daughter
that exact prompt
giving her quote unquote writing prompts
that he could read and enjoy
there would be no question that it's
illegal
that this is the sexual harassment and
abuse of a child
he's not gonna be able to hide behind
any well it's for for educational
purposes i was worried about her uh you
know creative writing i was trying to
help her build her creative writing
skills
he wouldn't be able to hide behind that
and yet if it if it happens in a
classroom
it's okay
why
you know no if anything
it's worse in a classroom
they can't really get worse but if it's
the fact that it's in a classroom if
that affects the severity of the crime
at all it's only to make it worse
because these are adults that you have
entrusted your children with
and their job is to educate your
children
and when they use that trust
and that role
to sexually indoctrinate
abuse and harass kids it makes it even
worse
so this is exactly what should happen
not just for this but uh
distributing
sex ed
material
with unnecessarily graphic pictures and
depictions and descriptions
we we all know the story i've talked
about many of them on the show over the
years
you know sex ed for middle schoolers it
talks about
masturbation and sodomy and anal sex and
all kinds of things that's that's
happening in schools all across the
country
and this is the point that i've always
made about it
that these conversations if you were to
take them out of the classroom and put
them on the playground between the adult
and the child or put them and put them
online or anywhere else
we would all of us unquestioningly agree
that this is sexual abuse and that
person's a pervert and a pedophile and
should be locked in prison
so the only thing that i would add to
them what the mayor said here is uh is
yeah certainly
[Music]
the the board of education should resign
or be arrested
and all of the teachers who distributed
this and who are involved in this every
single one of them should be should be
in prison
they shouldn't be able to hide behind
what was the curriculum i had no choice
the curriculum called for me to solicit
x-rated material from fourteen-year-olds
mayor craig schubert 2024
i've decided he's my uh
ron is saying i still like desantis but
for me right now schubert is uh
has just has just gone to the lead
all right speaking of uh the sexual
abuse of minors yesterday four gymnasts
testified about the abuse they suffered
at the hands of larry nasser as the
olympic team doctor who's now in prison
uh where all sexual abusers should be
including the ones in the public school
system
and specifically they were talking about
how the fbi failed to help them or or
even help to cover up the crime
so all of their accounts were uh pretty
shocking and important i'll play one of
them this is michaela maroney
talking about her experiences and
especially
the fbi's reaction or lack of reaction i
should say
listen
good morning thank you chairman durbin
ranking member grassley and members of
the judiciary committee for inviting me
to speak today
as most of you are probably aware i was
molested by the u.s gymnastics national
team and olympic team doctor larry
nassar in actuality he turned out to be
more of a pedophile than he was a doctor
what i'm trying to bring to your
attention today is something incredibly
disturbing and illegal
after telling my entire story of abuse
to the fbi in the summer of 2015
not only did the fbi not report my abuse
but when they eventually documented my
report 17 months later they made
entirely false claims about what i said
after reading the office of inspector
general's oig report i was shocked and
deeply disappointed at this narrative
they chose to fabricate they chose to
lie about what i said and protect a
serial child molester rather than
protect not only me but countless others
now as i said she was not the only one
to tell the same story about the fbi in
fact we have one more clip we'll play
the other one too uh because this is
important this is maggie nichols
with a disturbingly similar story to
tell listen
despite these findings of serious and
criminal misconduct throughout the fbi
usag and usopc no accountability has
occurred an important question remains
perhaps the most important question why
why would the fbi agents lie to oig
investigators why would the fbi not
properly document evidence that was
received why would the fbi agent be
interested in the usag presidency these
questions remain unanswered
and the survivors of larry nassar have a
right to know why their well-being was
placed in the jeopardy by these
individuals who
chose not to do their jobs
to date no one from the fbi the us opc
or usag has faced federal charges other
than larry nassar for many hundreds of
survivors of larry nassar this hearing
is one of our last opportunities to get
justice
we ask that you
do what is in your power to ensure those
that engaged in wrongdoing are held
accountable under the law
yeah these i wish we would say these
claims are are shocking but
given what we know about the fbi
at this point they really aren't
i mean what's being alleged here is the
fbi
essentially participating
in a cover-up
of the uh the serial abuse sexual abuse
of of
kids
we have to understand the corruption in
our government
the rot in our government
is
incredibly deep
at every single level especially in the
federal government
which is why in 2024
there's not going to be any
republican who can
solve all of these problems
but at a minimum
we talk about what we should be looking
for in a in a 2024 republican candidate
one of the number one things we should
be looking for
is someone
who we have reason to believe
will get in there
and start
cleaning these people out
start sifting through all of this and
rooting through all of the corruption
and um
holding these people accountable
or at a minimum getting them out
the you know that's that's a that's a
more wordy way of saying drain the swamp
which is what we heard about in 2016 and
um i think it was it was a good plan
it's a good motto it's a good plan it's
exactly what needs to happen it's very
swampy in dc and we do need to drain it
problem is that trump got in there in
2016 no matter how you feel about trump
there's no denying the fact that he
didn't drain anything he did not drain
the swamp at all he didn't get rid of
any of these people he didn't clean up
any of this
and he didn't try so you can't say well
he tried his best and no he really
didn't
what what did he do where's the evidence
that he tried to clean up any of this
mess
to locate
uh any of this corruption and expel the
people responsible for it
no he didn't because trump was
almost entirely concerned
with uh people that were you know
personal slights and personal attacks
against himself and responding to those
and that's it's fine to respond to
personal attacks
but we're also going to need a
republican who's focused on on a more on
a broader scale like cleaning up the
government
uh i think there's good reason to to
to believe in fact we know from what
we've seen ron de santos do in florida
that he will do that
even better that mayor in ohio i mean we
know he's going to start arresting the
school board
it's that kind of aggressiveness that we
need if we're not going to get that
then you might as well not have a
republican at all
you know if if republicans
not going to start cleaning this up
then you we may as well not you might as
well just have a democrat
because then you have a republican
sitting atop this whole mountain of
corruption and filth
he's sitting atop this this decaying
garbage heap
and if he doesn't get out a shovel and
start shoveling this stuff away
then he's going to be ineffectual as a
president and once he leaves that
garbage heap remains
all right uh what else we got here
well this was interesting alexandria
casey cortez we know about her at the
met gala saying tax the rich
there are some people who've uh who've
claimed that well
aoc says tax the rich she's rich what
about that
and she actually responded on on
instagram to that charge of you know
people say people argue that you want to
tax rich but you're also rich
and aoc says well yeah but when i say
rich people i don't mean myself here's
her explanation i mean this is the trick
that people use all the time right they
want you to think that when we talk
about rich we're talking about a doctor
or a lawyer instead of someone with
hundreds of millions of dollars if not
billions of dollars that's what we mean
by rich
oh that's the
that's that's this is the trick people
pull all the time holding me to my own
standard i i know your game i know what
you're up to
expecting me to have one standard
this is this is a misogynistic ploy it's
a patriarchy at it again
oh no the rich are just however
as as my wealth grows
rich is always one step above wherever i
am
that's the real answer that's why bernie
sanders for years and years i mean
decades was ranting about millionaires
and billionaires and then this most
recent go round
in this most recent campaign you started
to notice that he wasn't talking about
millionaires anymore he was only talking
about billionaires why is that well
because he became a millionaire and so
now we're not worried about millionaires
we're worried about billionaires
that's that's the real answer
by the way you should know that when we
talk about
the top one percent of income earners
and usually democrats
like bernie sanders
they're always railing against the top
one percent the one percenters we've
heard about that for years
well to get into the top one percent of
income earners you need to be earning i
think it's
don't quote me on this off the top of my
head i think it's like 500 000 a year or
something like that
you you don't need to be a millionaire
to be in the top one percent of income
earners
and that you know that
by any measure uh if if you're in the
top one percent of income earners
in any you know wherever you live then
you're you're rich because rich is
always
comparative it's always relative
always going to be rich relative to
everybody else
um
you know even people
in this country if you're in the top
80 of income earners you're going to be
rich compared to
the vast majority of the globe
compared to someone living in a hut in
some poverty-stricken area of india for
example you're gonna be to be in the top
80 makes you rich
so it's always relative in this country
though yeah one percent yeah that's
gotta has to qualify as rich
but you don't need to be a
multi-millionaire
far from it
and of course
as i as i tried to explain at the
beginning of the week
um
tax the rich yeah absolutely of course
we should tax the rich
i i i'm not aware of that i've never
heard anyone argue that we shouldn't tax
the rich at all
i don't think anyone's arguing that
i i haven't heard anyone argue that that
the rich should not pay
more than everybody of course they
should
now that doesn't necessarily mean that
they should pay a higher percentage
now we're getting into should we have a
progressive tax rate or not
but even if we have a flat tax and they
pay the same percentage they're still
paying a lot more
um as a as a
in terms of of you know the the overall
amount of money
so i haven't heard anyone anyone argue
that and we do tax the rich
and the rich pay almost all of the taxes
in this
country
there are great many americans who when
it comes to income tax pay nothing
at all
now to me that seems unfair
you know
if we're going to have an income tax and
i think you can make a really good
argument for having no income tax at all
but if we're going to have an income tax
everybody with an income should
participate
that's the real unfairness here
and as i said i don't care you wanna you
wanna
you wanna raise jeff bezos's taxes
doesn't bother me i don't care
i'm not gonna lose any sleep at night if
you raise taxes on
the ceo of amazon
but as a matter of record and as a
matter of being accurate we have to say
that
he already actually does pay taxes just
so you know
and the other problem is that
when the government comes in and takes
money from rich people
okay
but now the government has that money
so when i think about jeff bezos
and his billions of dollars
you know either he's going to have those
billions or the government will have it
i don't trust the government with
anyone's money
they rake in trillions of dollars a year
in tax revenue
and they squander
almost all of it
and many times squandering is the the
best we could hope for is that they'll
just waste it or burn it and put it all
in a pile and burn it
because a lot of because they also use a
good portion that money to advance an
ideological and cultural agenda that i
absolutely
oppose they're taking a certain portion
of it giving it to planned parenthood
for example
and that's
you hear you know conservatives
not every conservative is libertarian
when it comes to taxes and that's
perfectly fine
but when you hear conservatives argue
for raising taxes on the rich
um
in principle i don't have necessarily an
issue with that argument but you but you
do realize it's
it's our government that's going to end
up with that money that's that's what
raising the taxes mean now they have it
do you trust them with it
yeah you don't trust jeff trust jeff
bezos with his money but do you trust
alexandria ocasio-cortez with it do you
trust joe biden with it
i don't
all right um
prince this from the evening standard it
says prince harry and meghan markle have
said they are humbled to be featured in
time magazine's 100 most influential
people list
the couple addressed the milestone on
the archwell website following the news
their statement read prince harry and
megan the duke and duchess of sussex are
not only humbled to be part of this
year's time 100 through the words of and
of friend and partner jose andrus uh but
uh blah blah blah who cares what they
say okay
they were named one of the most
influential people on the globe here's
the
cover picture there
and harry this is a very sad story harry
has become the literal picture of a
better male he's he's become
look at him there you see in the picture
you've got meghan markle kind of
standing proud broad-shouldered
and then prince harry is crouched behind
her clinging onto her shoulder
this is what he's become
was it worth it harry that's the
question
but really i shouldn't be commenting on
this because we know that meghan markle
and prince harry
the one thing they want
in this world most of all
is uh their privacy they just want their
privacy to be respected
so they're starring on the on
yet again another magazine cover they've
been on about uh 57 magazine covers
in the last
two and a half months
but they just want their privacy won't
all of you please leave them alone fine
come to their house take the picture for
the magazine cover they'll issue their
statement but then leave them alone
please
these are very private and humble people
as far as them being influential i'm not
exactly sure what what are they
influencing who are they influencing
is there anyone who wants to step up to
the plate here and say that they've been
influenced
by
megan and harry in what way
influence to the point of nausea perhaps
maybe that kind of influence
all right one other story here this is
an interesting one uh get away from from
politics for a moment
this is from the hill it says a first of
its kind startup officially launched on
monday with a bold mission
that pushes the boundaries of flora and
fauna conservation
to de-extinct the woolly mammoth
colossal a bioscience and genetics
company with 15 million dollars raised
in private investment aims to revive
animal species that have long been
classified as extinct beginning with the
woolly mammoth and ancestor of today's
elephants that died out during the
holocene epoch uh over 11 000 years ago
uh epoch whatever
company leadership intends to resurrect
the woolly mammoth using genetic
sequencing and editing technology
from there colossal will cultivate a
de-extinction library of animals to
resuscitate into the modern world
it also aims to harvest dna and embryos
from currently endangered species
to prevent similar extinction patterns
so this is this is what they're going to
do they're actually going to try to do
it
make a wooly mammoth and plop them down
up there in the arctic
i guess the most obvious question is why
why do we feel the need to do this
haven't we already seen from the science
fiction films how this works out
and but you could also make the argument
that
clearly society is heading downhill
we're heading towards catastrophe and
and an apocalypse anyway and so if this
is kind of a
choose-your-own-adventure novel we have
to decide
how humanity is going to go extinct
then um you know this this is one of the
more interesting and attractive
propositions i suppose
to bring all these prehistoric creatures
back to uh to life and then they can
destroy you know maybe that's one way to
do it
this is the kind of you know
there's there's the more exotic version
of animal conservation where it's not
really conservation we're bringing
animals back to life
i think i think most people will agree i
hope that that's a few steps to too far
but even normal conservation i think
goes too far sometimes
and you're
most people are not ready for this
conversation but for example
pandas shouldn't exist
do you know how much effort
human beings have put into keeping
pandas these totally useless animals who
cannot survive on their own how much
effort we've put into keeping these
animals alive
and why because they're cute that's the
only reason
millions of animal species go extinct
and then we select certain ones and we
say well those are cute let's keep them
around
pandas have been trying to make
themselves extinct for decades
they don't want to mate anymore
they just hang out up in the trees
waiting to die off
and we're doing everything we can to
keep them around
i have a real grudge against pandas but
that's a story for another time all
right let's go to reading the uh youtube
comments
[Music]
[Music]
that's it
i can play the whole song
come on after all this build up we play
five seconds of the song
all right
um
maximilian says
quote when you start thinking that
you're really good at something just
remember there's a three-year-old kid in
china that will do it ten times better
than you ever will unquote
maximilian
mk jill wait a second did you just quote
yourself
so the user maximilian mk gill
quotes himself and then okay you're
banned from the show what are you what
are you doing
jerry d white says would matt be willing
to do a reaction video to the matrix
resurrections trailer
i'm not going to do a whole video about
it i did watch the trailer
uh you know before i watched it because
they're coming out with a matrix four
now there was there was the first matrix
which is the only matrix that exists as
far as i'm concerned and the other two
which were terrible now they're coming
out with a fourth one now you have to
understand already there is there is
zero chance okay just you know
zero chance that the movie is good
there has never been a case where you
had a movie
and then one or two sequels that were
terrible
and then another sequel that was good it
doesn't work that way
it's already difficult enough to think
of examples of good sequels
i mean in the history of hollywood
sequels there have been like four that
were good
um but there's certainly never been an
example where
the franchise takes a nosedive
and then you come out with another movie
and uh and it's actually good it doesn't
just doesn't work that way so you
already know that it's going to be bad
but i there's all this hype about the
trailer i watched the trailer and i i
just thought
i didn't like it at all
it's an entirely different aesthetic for
one thing the tone everything about it
feels different
but what they've done is um
as far as the plot from what i can tell
it
they're redoing the first matrix
so in the movie based on the trailer neo
is back in the matrix again and he's
forgotten all about his past
and so now he needs a new morpheus to
come
and give him the the choice between
pills and
we're going to redo the whole the first
movie again
um i i don't see the point to it i know
the point for the movie studios is to
make millions of dollars and i'm sure
they'll do that but
as a fan i don't know why you give your
money and sit down to watch that story
when you know that it's going to be it's
an inferior pale imitation of the first
movie
um seth says i hope that if matt ever
did go to the met gala he'd wear a shirt
that said taxation is theft no i'd wear
an spg shirt of course which is on sale
now uh for the low price of 96
and you should go pick one up i wouldn't
wear a taxationist theft shirt because
taxation is not theft you know i'm not
an anarchist i believe that we do
need some kind of government and i've
never heard a compelling proposal for
how we can maintain a government without
taxes so there have to be taxes i think
there are too many taxes i i think the
taxes are too high in most cases
i think the money is spent in the wrong
way but taxation itself
as a concept is not theft
you might be able to argue
that some taxation is theft
i i might even agree that the income tax
is theft
not taxation itself but the income tax
with the withholding system
the idea that the government can just
dip into your paycheck and take your
money as it stands right now
the government
goes into your your paycheck and takes a
portion of your check before you get
your hands on it so they take what they
want and they give you the rest
and that's the system we've had ever
since the withholding system was put in
place
decades ago
i i think you could make a very good
argument against that
but
as a general principle no
another comment says the part where matt
pauses
uh for the moist meat sponsor certified
classic no it's
it's moic meat it's not moist meat
i think you know that
another comment says today i learned
sweet daddy walsh and i both hate the
same kind of events if there's no
activity or something to do it's a
nightmare
i don't want to mill around exchanging
small talk with people i don't know or
like yeah um i think that's a that's an
introvert thing it's also a man thing
women just do better in those kinds of
uh situations it's like when women get
together like if my wife gets together
with her friends
they'll kind of you know just like sit
around
talking for for 17 hours in a row and
won't do anything
but for men
you know we need like you get together
you watch the game right you you play
poker like you need some central
activity
um
and then you can build the conversation
around that
and finally magnum says you're not
protecting children walsh you're merely
trying to impose your narrow views on
them and make them act and appear in a
way you find acceptable
it's no wonder you hate our education
system because the education system
clearly failed you
yeah my narrow views
on children like my narrow view that
biology exists
my narrow view that if you're a male
with a penis and xy chromosomes you're
not a female
all of the narrow views that you can
find in any biology textbook for second
graders
that's that's my narrow view
also that um you know girls should not
be subjected to the presence of of boys
in their locker room they should get
privacy another narrow view of mine
you're right yeah those are those are
narrow views in a certain way and i do
want to impose them on on children i
want to pose them on the entire world if
i could
i would love to impose basic sanity on
everyone if i could do that i would
guilty as charged
say you know the past couple of weeks
have been demoralizing for americans
everywhere last thursday biden announced
his plan to mandate vaccines for all
companies with over 100 employees or
test them for covet at least once a week
the daily wire has over 100 employees
ourselves and is refusing to subject
their employees to this violation of
their personal medical freedom for this
daily wire could face up to 14 000 for
each violation and i can't think of a
better reason to let the fines pile up
than for opposing medical tyranny and
the erasure of freedom that's why we're
calling on all who are listening to help
the daily wire fight this obscene and
tyrannical mandate if you join us at
delhi wire member right now you'll be
supplying the resources needed to take
this all the way to the supreme court if
necessary so go to dailywire.com
subscribe and use code do not comply at
checkout for 25 off also
dailywire's mission has always been to
put the facts first which is why the
morning wire was created
to serve exactly that need it's it's the
daily morning show dedicated to bringing
you all the news you need to know
without any spin or hidden agenda it's
the only daily podcast that values your
time and the truth
and while we're working overtime to make
sure fact-based news still has a
platform we need your help to keep it
trending towards number one so subscribe
and start listening now to morning wire
on apple spotify or wherever you listen
to podcast and leave a five-star review
if you like what you hear but wait
there's more
big news daily wire is starting an
official e-commerce division of our
company and we're now searching for a
vice president of e-commerce to join our
team in nashville tennessee in this
exceptional leadership opportunity you
will oversee the daily wire division
that birthed the legendary leftist tears
tumbler
you know what you'll also be able to do
you'll be able to sell the sweet baby
gang
t-shirts
using our your autonomy and e-commerce
expertise you and your team will be the
force behind daily wires e-commerce
presence and consumer experience
expressing the full creativity wit and
wisdom that will encompass the daily
wire brand and the sweet baby gang brand
most importantly if you think you've got
what it takes to be the newest critical
addition to the daily wire leadership
team and promulgate the mission of the
sweet baby gang slash the daily wire
through e-commerce we want to hear from
you for 4d for full details on the
responsibilities and requirements of
this position and to apply visit
dailywire.com careers our full list of
current openings on the daily wire team
can be found there as well now let's get
to our daily cancellation
[Music]
on saturday night boxing fans who were
willing to pay 50 for the pay-per-view
due presumably to undiagnosed mental
illness on their part we're treated to
the spectacle of 44 year old former ufc
champion vitor belfort
fighting 59 year old evandra holyfield
the fight went exactly as you'd imagine
that it would go given that one of the
men involved will soon start collecting
social security holyfield
stumbled and bumbled around the ring for
a few minutes before getting knocked out
the once great boxer is still in great
shape for a man of his advanced age
and he could certainly still kick the
crap out of me which is why i wouldn't
be doing this segment if he was sitting
in the room with me but he's not
but he's way too old to be in the boxing
ring
the fight never should have been allowed
to happen nobody should have paid to
watch it and holy feels lucky that he's
escaping without any major injuries
speaking of things that shouldn't have
been allowed to happen the very next
night
less than 24 hours after a man pushing
60 got chased around a boxing ring for
the sick pleasure of people who enjoy
watching elder abuse the 63 year old
madonna stood on stage at the vmas in an
age-appropriate coat only to strip it
off and reveal the horrifying dominatrix
gear underneath she then turned around
to show off her thong which was
accentuating what appeared to be her
prosthetically enhanced and enhanced
buttocks she then hobbled off the stage
and drove to denny's where she received
15 off the bill with her aarp discount
of course i'm just kidding madonna
hasn't eaten a full meal since 1983. it
has been a week full of
strange geriatric spectacles and it's
not over
on friday clint eastwood
will release his latest film
at the age of 91 he directs and stars in
a movie called cry macho
which is about a grizzled ex-rodeo star
who ends up escorting a young boy across
mexico for some reason or another while
bad guys chased them close behind
from what i've read the film depicts
eastwood at various points
beating a guy up
riding and taming a wild mustang
and even attracting the attention of a
young beautiful woman who at one point
begs him to you know jump in the sack
with her
eastwood is again 91 years old
the movie we should note is based on a
novel about a past his prime rodeo star
but in the novel past his prime means 38
years old eastwood is old enough to be
the great grandfather of the character
that his character is based on
it all sounds quite silly and a little
sad but still not as sad as the recent
de niro movie the irishman from a couple
years ago where de niro in his late 70s
portrays a tough gangster in his 30s
somewhat infamously the role requires
the nearly 80-year-old de niro playing
the 30-something-year-old tough guy to
physically manhandle and intimidate a
shopkeeper who shoved his daughter the
scene is unintentionally hilarious let's
uh let's watch that now
stay here
right i'm sorry but your kid was out of
line
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
you can see the young girl looking on in
horror because she's afraid that grandpa
will break his hip doing that
and get used to that sort of thing
there's a new action-packed indiana
jones coming out this year starring
harrison ford at 80 years old
we'll be able to spend a whole 90
minutes watching an actor born during
the roosevelt administration square off
against bad guys who will all obligingly
agree to be physically defeated by a man
who they could knock over with a feather
hopefully the movie will be out soon but
production was halted for a time because
harrison ford broke his shoulder during
filming
why did he break his shoulder well
because again he's 80 years old
look it's not my intention to take cheap
shots at these people i i believe in
respecting my elders it's just difficult
sometimes when they're prancing around
in a leather thong on stage
in fact i think all of this is a symptom
of our culture's lack of respect for
aging
we refuse to acknowledge that aging is a
reality at all that's how we end up with
a 59 year old boxer
and 80 year old action stars and 63 year
old half-naked pop stars it's also how
we end up with a 78 year old president
in fact
if you follow the presidential chain of
succession
three of the four camila harris aside
are nearly 80 or above 80.
the average age in the senate is 63 and
that makes them sound younger than they
really are
it's actually the oldest senate in
history with a good portion of the
highest ranking in most influential
senators pushing 90.
nancy pelosi over in the house is
practically a teenager at 81 in
comparison to you know some of her
colleagues
meanwhile it should be mentioned that
our pandemic response has been guided
for a year and a half by anthony fauci
who turned 80 in december
so what is happening here
we're a country run not by the older
but by the very elderly
how is that happening and how does it
happen especially in a culture that
worships youth
you would think if anything we'd be
making the opposite mistake you'd think
we'd have lowered the presidential age
limit and put a 14 year old in the white
house by now
there seems to be a contradiction or a
tension between our worship of youth and
our political and cultural institutions
being led by people who statistically
will probably be dead of old age within
five years
but the apparent contradiction
disappears
when you spend a little more time
thinking about it
the common thread is that we hate the
idea of aging
we hate the reality of aging and we
again absolutely refuse to acknowledge
that that reality exists or to take it
into account
even now you'll still hear people even
critics of biden who insist that there's
nothing necessarily wrong with electing
a 78 year old to the white house
78 year olds are just as capable as
anybody else age is just a number they
say
it's a coincidence that this 78 year old
is suffering the exact sort of mental
and physical decline that you would
expect any 78 year old to suffer if put
into that
position this we have decided
is how we respect and honor older people
by pretending that they're not older
by pretending that they can still do all
of the things that they could do 50
years ago
by electing them president and clapping
when they take their clothes off on
stage
and pretending not to find it silly when
they make movies about themselves
beating people up at the age of 91.
we also respect older people by not
asking them about their age because your
age the number of years you've been
alive
is embarrassing for some reason
and we do it by congratulating elderly
women who use collagen and silicone to
approximate the appearance of women half
their age but this is all the opposite
of respecting your elders
you can't respect that which you pretend
does not exist
part of respect by definition is
recognition
you cannot respect someone of an
advanced age if you refuse to recognize
their advanced age and what it means
it's not hard to see why our culture has
taken this turn we're terrified of aging
and we would rather elect a 78 year old
president than admit that 78 year olds
are too old to be president
we're terrified of that because we're
terrified of death
age and death are inextricably tied to
each other the older you get the closer
you are to death death becomes more and
more a part of your life as you age your
friends and family start to die parts of
yourself start to die
your youthful looks your athletic
ambitions many of your physical talents
dwindle over time until they're
extinguished
our response to this process and it's a
sad process
is to deny it completely
to say age is just a number are you
gonna it's not just a number it is a
physical reality
but the honorable and dignified approach
is to embrace
this process
because if you embrace it
then you earn something in exchange
you earn wisdom and insight and
understanding
cultures that really respect their
elders they don't turn them into
athletes or pop stars or action heroes
or even presidents but they turn them
into wise counselors
village elders
people whose depth and breadth of
experience have granted them a certain
perception and a certain awareness that
the rest of us lack
that's how you honor aging
and and the aged
and that is why
evander holyfield
is cancelled
had to cancel someone at the end i
wasn't sure who it's got to be him
and that'll do it for us today thanks
for watching thanks for listening have a
great day godspeed
[Music]
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover our technical director is austin
stevens
production manager pavel vadosky
the show is edited by ali hinkle
our audio is mixed by mike coromina hair
makeup is done by cherokee heart and our
production coordinator is mckenna waters
the matte wall show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire
dailywire2021
gavin newsom survives his recall
election nicki minaj
shows the political realignment that's
going on and aoc reveals herself to be
an establishment chill check it out on
the michael knowles show
[Music]